نظل هيك عيش حياته رح يضل لحاله مثل
الكابوس
في حدا عنجد تحس فيه مش تحطف معي
هدول سرقوا اغلى شيء بحياتك
ما فيك تتركن تمشي حجره يلي تشكلت فيها
المشكله الاساسيه والحدث الرئيسي للعمل
الطفل يلي صار عنده فصام وبعدين هذا
الفصام اخدوا الاماكن عديده وطرق كثيره
يعني فلذلك هو الحجره
اني ما بسمع صوتي في شغله موجوده بكل
البلدان العربيه نحنا وصغار اذا ما بعرف
بمصر شو بقولوا الفئران
لما كان الاهل يهددوا ابنهم
يعني
قط الفئران بتاعه كل بيت يعني
بيهددوا فيها اولاد صغار
كلنا بخطر انا حرفيا وصفه لحال اللي نحن
عليه اليوم الاعمال النفسيه ما بنعملها
بالعالم العربي فرح فورا يصير في مقاربه
بيننا وبين الاعمال الاخرى الاجنبيه
فالحفاظ على الاصاله وعلى البيئه وعلى
تفاصيلنا الحياتيه واللي بهمنا حافظنا
عليه بشكل كتير منيح بعيدا عن الكون
الشخصيه هي منفصمه وعم تعمل هاي السلوكات
لكن الاصاله مشاكلنا
الغدر الخيانه العدل كل هدول الفضاءات
عالجناهم يلي نحن بحاجه بحاجه معالجه لهذه
المواضيع بمجتمعنا
فبعتقد نحن كتير اصيلين رح نكون ما راح
نشوف شغله كوبي اوريجينال عن اي شيء ثاني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تواجه خصم عملاق ما بيخسر حاليا
هو
بيرتبط بشكل كتير كتير
مناسب لعمل
محتوى عربي وبنفس
الافكار بتكون متقدمه شوي
المحتوى
بيك
والوحش اللي جواته عم يطلع نوعيه
المسلسلات اللي بتكون لما كان لها ظروفها
يعني
سيئاتها انه المشاهد ما بحس حاله بينتمي
للبيئه اللي عم يشوفها يعني انا برايي اهم
عنصر من عناصر نجاح العمل انه المتلقي يحس
حاله ممكن يكون واحد من الاشخاص اللي عم
يشوفهم بالعمل فالبية بس في مسلسلات
النوعيه يعني نوعيه او ظروفها بتفرض عليك
مثلا اذا عم تعملي مثلا مسلسل
السياسي او اي شيء ما فيك تروحي اكثر صوت
بتحدد المكان وزمان فبتروح يعني
براسك هيدي وهم
كتير النقاط الحقيقه بس انا برشح التمثيل
انا برايي التمثيل بشكل خاص يعني الدور
اللي عملوا البطل محمد الاحمر يعني صراحه
تمثيليا صعب جدا
يمكن كثير قلال ممكن يعملوا
هي راح تكون العامل الاسئله
للعمل
ناس راح تعمل الحلقه